تعتبر الخرسانة والصلب مفيدة للغاية، ولم نكن لنكون
قادرين على أن نكون حيث نحن
في الوقت الحالي إذا لم يكن لدينا
الخرسانة والصلب في المائة عام الماضية
أو نحو ذلك، لكنهم يفرضون
عقوبات على
[  بيئة الموسيقى
هي مجموعة بحثية صغيرة ضمن
الممارسة المعمارية والغرض منها
هو التعاون مع
الناس لدراسة الجوانب في محيط الهندسة
المعمارية. الميليوم هو في الأساس
الكائن الحي الذي تمتلكه الزهور في عيش الغراب
والفطر وبنية تحت الأرض
وهي في الواقع  كائن حي وهو
هيكل ذكي جدًا، يمكنك زراعة
الميسيليوم بسهولة تامة، لذلك يمكن زراعة الميليوم
في بيئة معملية صغيرة لدينا،
فنحن نصنع أشياء عن طريق النمو عن طريق
إدخال جراثيم الميليوم في ركيزة من
رقائق الخشب أو الكتان أو
شيء من هذا القبيل، وينمو كل شيء  معًا
في غضون أسبوعين، وإذا صنعنا
قوالب لها، فيمكننا أن ننموها إلى
أشكال ويمكن بعد ذلك تجفيف الأشكال، وهي
أشياء ثابتة تمامًا
يمكنك الإمساك بها ولديها
قدر معين من القوة التي تتمتع بها حقًا
سلوك صوتي جيد يمكنهم استيعابه وإصدار
الصوت ولديهم معدل جيد إلى حد ما من الحرائق
لتحويله إلى
مادة بناء مناسبة حيث أمامنا
طريق طويل لنقطعه ولكن كما أظهرنا في
أسبوع تصميم كلار أندويل هذا العام في
الصيف في لندن  لقد صنعنا 82 قطعة من الطوب وقمنا
بتكديسها وقمنا بإنشاء أشياء منها ومقاعد وقطعة من الجدار
وطاولة، أحد الأشياء التي
يمكننا القيام بها كمهندسين معماريين هو النظر إلى
مواد أفضل للبناء إذا
نظرنا إلى المواد  لاستبدال
الخرسانة، سنتمكن من توفير الكثير
من مشاكل الطاقة والكربون
التي نواجهها